bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados una nueva carrera
por el espacio ya despegó
en 2021 se realizaron 134 lanzamientos
espaciales para poner en órbita naves
son humanos algo sin precedentes en la
historia y para 2022 se prevén unos 200
lanzamientos y la luna será el astro más
visitado en que se basa esta carrera
quienes son los principales competidores
y cuáles son las metas detrás de todo
ello como decíamos el principal objetivo
ahora es la luna eeuu y china enviarán
misiones pero también lo harán japón
rusia india corea del sur y emiratos
árabes unidos estados unidos prevé
patrocinar 18 viajes junto a otros 13
países trabajan en la misión artemis en
honor a la diosa griega de la luna con
esta misión la nasa planea hacer
realidad la llegada de una mujer y una
persona afrodescendiente por primera vez
a la luna y busca crear en su órbita una
estación espacial que se llamará gateway
se espera que esté lista para 2024
desde gateway se buscará que los
astronautas puedan volver a pisar el
suelo lunar en 2000 5 algo que no se
logra desde 1972 la diferencia de esta
misión con la famosa misión apolo de la
guerra fría es que las incursiones a la
luna se harían desde gateway y no desde
cohetes que despegan de la tierra en la
construcción de esta estación participan
canadá la unión europea y japón y
también lo hacen en el desarrollo de
naves compañías privadas como spacex del
magnate y lo más que china y rusia
anunciaron un proyecto que competirá con
artemis este busca construir también una
estación en la órbita lunar y a la vez
una base en la superficie de la luna y
pretenden que ambas puedan estar
habitadas para 2036 tanto la misión
artemis de la nasa como el proyecto
chino ruso buscan usar los recursos en
el terreno esto con el objetivo de
aliviar los altos costos de transportar
materiales fuera de la tierra la mira
está puesta en el agua cuya existencia
en la luna se confirmó en 2008 y en la
piedra triturada o regolito este último
se intentará procesar y convertir en
materia prima para posteriormente
construir bases
con impresoras 300 el trasfondo de
artemis es enviar tecnología a la luna
para hacer sostenibles las misiones
espaciales y luego trasladar esta
experiencia a martín por su parte de
corea del sur planea colocar una nave
espacial en la órbita lunar y emiratos
árabes unidos se enviará un vehículo de
exploración a su superficie además hay
varias misiones fuera de la luna la nasa
planea estudiar las rocas espaciales
entre marte y júpiter y el choque de una
nave espacial con un asteroide esto con
el objetivo de desviar su trayectoria y
así prevenir una eventual amenaza a la
tierra en el futuro por su parte la
agencia espacial europea enviará una
sonda a las lunas de júpiter un espacio
que nunca ha sido explorado todo ello
sin nombrar tres misiones iniciadas en
2020 por china eeuu y emiratos árabes
unidos- de manera independiente de sus
tres países lanzaron sondas vehículos de
exploración y orbitadores al planeta
rojo con el fin
más información sobre el información que
pronto conoceremos para este año se
prevé también que la estación espacial
china tiangong en la órbita de la tierra
esté en pleno funcionamiento es una base
que cuenta con armas antimisiles un
informe de inteligencia de eeuu la
describió como uno de los puntos claves
en la lucha de china para igualar o
superar el poder militar de eeuu en
cuanto a los intereses privados más
pretende que sus naves lleven en los
próximos años colonos a marte mientras
que el magnate jeff bezos con su empresa
blue origin en busca que los recursos
lunares se puedan aprovechar para erigir
nuevas industrias como la extracción de
materias primas a qué se debe el
resurgimiento de la carrera espacial los
objetivos son varios hay intereses
científicos para entender la historia
del espacio y la posibilidad de vida
fuera de la tierra también económicos
por los posibles recursos que se puedan
encontrar fuera de ella y por supuesto
estratégicos el pentágono
a la luna como el nuevo terreno en
disputa y es que el dominio del espacio
y los satélites que se puedan colocar en
él determinarán el dominio militar en la
tierra dejando atrás la guerra fría con
eeuu oponiéndose a la unión soviética en
todos los frentes ahora la competencia
es entre washington y beijing
la nueva carrera a la luna y al espacio
se puede resumir como dos modelos
opuestos en disputa el de occidente en
el que colaboran varios países y
empresas privadas y el oriental liderado
básicamente por china y rúsia con
modelos de gobierno más autoritarios
sin duda los próximos años serán
decisivos para múltiples descubrimientos
espaciales y para determinar el poderío
de china o eeuu por el título de la
primera potencia mundial si le sirvió el
vídeo para entender las claves de la
nueva carrera espacial los esperamos en
otro episodio de cinco minutos en france
24 y france24 puntocom